[Music]
there was no known precedent for the
impact of this pandemic
[Music]
you've never seen room like this before
no no never
Italians had to learn the horrors as
they were living them as the country
watched the human catastrophe unfold
Italy's government called the first
block down in Europe
whew here could have predicted how long
it would last
from the very first days of lockdown it
was clear the country was in a state of
high anxiety we've our como se sentir
momento momento para la chaine de una
parada
Laura leopolda you know the myth but
scratch the surface and the emotion was
everywhere Aurelio was waiting to be
served through a hatch at a pharmacy
along with food stores they were the
only shops still open
Italians seemed calm adapting to a way
of life few could have imagined but it
was clear almost everyone was dealing
with their own personal struggle there
is a big problem with the mind with the
depression with the answer anxiety and
are you worried for me there is enough
problem getting the free
amazing new situation really good
comeback the Sun Italians regularly took
to their windows and balconies to sing
and play music as they came together to
say Andhra tutto bené everything will be
alright
but few realized at the start what
lockdown would mean
three weeks became eight
[Music]
the deadline extended time and time
again
[Music]
the epicenter of the crisis was the
northern region of Lombardy but
containing the virus with a national
effort a strict countrywide lock down
the entire economy it has standstill
ciao the financial hardship began before
lockdown with Italy emptied of visitors
even essential workers considered lucky
were barely coping invincible in cranes
been sampling yes you we need journey
very own pizza hellebore o kumi bar zero
by just day five of lockdown
Stefano Capelli's taxi earnings had
already dropped to 30 euros a day input
quanto tempo really cozy you're seeing
was awesome fun
where they do it going on CCC citizen by
stefanos predictions he'd have run out
of money around three weeks ago
the crisis began to take its toll on all
Italians as they watched the horrors
unfold in the country's north
[Music]
live from Rome on the day Italy became
the epicenter of the covert 19 outbreak
[Music]
Italy became a country of unwelcome
first the first to show its hospitals
overrun with the sick
[Music]
the first to call in the army to
transport the dead what we were seeing
hearing was shocking
another big rise in Italian numbers yes
mark I can't quite believe we're seeing
these numbers 919 people have lost their
lives the last 24 hours in Italy there
was no frame of reference to predict the
events of this pandemic
this new designated covert hospital in
Rome wasn't yet at capacity but staff
clearly overworked already
we met medics on our tour we could feel
the weight on their shoulders the
pressure was palpable
but medical staff were also working with
the fear of contagion protective
equipment like this is essential but
hadn't been available in the early
outbreak the extreme precautions needed
to protect from this virus not fully
understood and this has cost the medical
community dearly more than a hundred and
eighty doctors and nurses have died of
covert 19 another to have taken their
lives in this period more than 300 staff
at this hospital alone have tested
positive the head of infectious diseases
here described the trauma of working
with the fear we wish you all the best
and we are thinking of you at the moment
thank you so much for your time today
what they were going through was awful
Italy saw how the virus spread at
frightening speed and the slow painful
fight needed to bring it under control
lockdown conditions were tightened
further still even exercise limited to
the close vicinity of your home the
sense of optimism and hope now hard to
find in the early days of lockdown you'd
see people singing at their windows and
balconies but you rarely see this at all
anymore it feels like the characteristic
warmth of Italians has been replaced by
an obsession with personal space even
the physical act of wearing a face mask
seems to have silenced people's spirits
this would have seemed inconceivable two
months ago now it's almost impossible to
imagine life as before
there's pressure to lift measures sooner
in the country south where infection is
lower but poverty far higher this man in
Apulia called police after being unable
to withdraw his mother's pension the
family's only income they begged the
officers to go to their home to see they
have no food reports emerged desperate
people were raiding supermarkets in
Sicily this fight breaking out in a shop
in Campania over someone not wearing a
face mask another video emerging of a
customer refusing to pay he has no money
he says but needs to eat as locked down
slowly loosens from the fourth of May
Italy is debating making face masks
mandatory outdoors at all times not just
on public transport and in shops and
police checkpoints are expected to stay
for some time yet CCF Letcher cordis son
he needs a document come here we've
become used to this regular checks to
verify why you're outside but life stuff
here even for those enforcing the rules
say in Boca loop Oh grazie Mille
the country with the longest lockdown in
Europe is one of the slowest to lift
measures Italy's neighbors were warned
of the horrors to come but here it was
too late to prepare lessons have been
learned from this nation's trauma and
Aurelia's words still ring true so many
weeks on achiever a super ahh his words
speak for the nation a nation that's had
no choice but to hold on and wait for
the darkness to slowly lift it's not
just people you hardly see here the sky
is empty to travel restrictions and
border closures have hurt Italy's
economy badly and even after lockdowns
lifted here it's likely to be sometime
before visitors return
there's usually a queue of tourists at
this doorway on Rome's Aventine hill the
long wait to look through its keyhole
worth it a perfect view of st. Peter's
Basilica the end of this crisis may feel
just as distant but it will end in this
ancient city and beautiful country will
rise again
you